[Music]
I think of anger as a gift why I reframe
it as a gift why I think of a Michael
Jordan example every time I get angry
Michael Jordan in the later stages of
his career I remember reading an
interview or quote with him someone said
you know how do you think about being
kind of an older player he was in his I
don't know if he was in it he was in his
mid-30s I think and you know surrounded
by all these younger players how do you
like get up the energy and he says when
I'm sitting on the bench before the game
I just think they say you are too old
they say you are too old they say you
are too old they say you are too old and
he has that son he created that
soundtrack see he's doing the same thing
he's dying he's tuning his brain he's
creating anger and then by the time the
bell rings and he leaps off the bench he
is so [ __ ] pissed off he goes any
crushes the opponents at age 35 and
they're all 10 years younger than him
anger is a gift you use it as fuel so
when publishers told me this is you know
when you know some agents or whatever
likely wouldn't even bother returning my
phone call and I talked to them at all
this makes physics and business in
history and I listen and you know they
kept doing this really irritating thing
of like scheduling something and then
like an hour before yeah can we do that
two weeks from now and then an hour
before can we do that a week from now
[ __ ] you I really pissed me off
like if you're not interested just say
you're not interested and keep like
Reese I'm still angry but you know what
I use it anger as fuel and I sit down in
the morning I think about that [ __ ] you
I'm gonna make this the best goddamn
book ever because are you [ __ ] you this
getting a little gay that's how anger is
a gift if I think in the Michael Jordan
example whether it's real or not and I'm
not really like infinitely upset about
that maybe just but you use it as fuel
and then
it's a gift and you know what I thank
all the people who rejected me because
they fueled me to make a better story
and and work harder so when I was
training every Eve essentially training
it's like shooting you know three-point
shots and lessly or shooting you know
free-throws endlessly it's fuel like you
imagine like they say you are too old
[ __ ] you I'm gonna do a hundred goddamn
free-throws alright so I'm going to read
you know every sentence of Nabokov and
deconstruct everything what he what are
those little tick tricks or tips whether
it's him or the because [ __ ] you and so
anger when someone screws you over it's
a gift and your job your trick is to
figure out how is it a gift
what are they helping you become better
at how are they providing you with fuel
they've just given you fuel how are you
going to use that fuel that's your job
you